instagram and facebook and whatsapp hit
by one of their longest ever service
outages today lasting several hours the
companies did not say what caused the
outage it comes as a data scientist from
facebook says the company would choose
its own interests over yours when it
discovered a conflict
but the company says the allegations are
misleading correspondent alexandria hoff
takes a look tonight at the latest
controversy concerning the social media
giant before she left facebook in may
product manager frances haugen secretly
made copies of tens of thousands of
documents she revealed her identity on
60 minutes as the whistleblower behind
the wall street journal's bombshell
investigation into facebook's knowledge
of the harm done to its users there were
conflicts of interest
between what was good for the public
and what was good for facebook
and facebook over and over again chose
to optimize for its own interests like
making more money haugens says she was
frustrated by facebook's lack of action
after internal research showed that the
platform and affiliated app instagram
was dangerous for teens
as these young women
begin to consume this eating disorder
content they get more and more depressed
it actually makes them use the app more
and so they end up in this feedback
cycle where they hate their bodies more
and more we're never going to be able to
eliminate the the basic human tendency
to compare yourself to others
in today's white house press briefing
press secretary jen saki voiced concern
from the biden administration efforts to
attract young users and negative effects
on teenagers mental health
are certainly troubling they're hardly
isolated incidents haugen will testify
tomorrow before a senate subcommittee
hearing titled protecting kids online
republican tennessee senator marsha
blackburn is the ranking member
the fact that they have moved forward
putting profit at the head of their list
and knowing that they were endangering
children those are issues that are of
concern
in a copy of haugen's written testimony
obtained by reuters the harvard grad
will liken facebook's practices to that
of big tobacco and will press lawmakers
to step in take action and regulate
reuters is also reporting that senator
amy klobuchar plans to ask how
facebook's algorithms might promote some
of this activity brett we'll follow it
alex thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else